So let's dive in.
Here are our kittens again.
By the way, that's Lyes,
the boy kitten on the right.
We don't have a name for the girl yet.
Anyway here's what a picture
element looks like.
You'll notice that this picture
element contains two source elements.
You might have seen those used for
video or audio elements.
Source elements do what you'd expect.
They provide optional file sources.
If the browser can use
the first source it will.
Otherwise, it keeps
looking down the list.
The picture element is a great way
to provide alternative sources for
image files.
So the browser can choose
depending on device capabilities.
We've used the source element
here to specify webp for
for browsers that support
the webp with a JPEG fallback.
This is a great way to make use of
the high performance webp format on
platforms that support it,
while providing an alternative for
platforms that don't.
You can find out more about webp from
the article linked to below the video.
By the way, that webp file is massive,
looks like I should have saved
it with lossy compression.
Talking about fall backs again,
what about browsers that don't
support the picture element?
Well, that's easy.
We just include a plain
old image element.
In fact,
the image element is non optional,
because that's the element that
actually displays the image.
The picture element scaffolding,
so to speak.
Simply tells the image
what source to choose.
In fact,
we can rewrite the example like this.
Because the browser defaults to
the image element if it can't use any of
the sources, earlier on you
learned about art direction.
One of the core problems you have
when serving images to a variety of
screen sizes and display sizes is
that although some images scale
quite nicely from large to small,
other images don't work so well.
They may have too much detail to
work well on a small screen or
be too wide to work on a view
port with a portrait orientation.